what's happening there reject nation
apologize for the delay on this one
we've only got a few more episodes left
though episode three after that
crazy cliffhanger
i'm excited to see what we got today
guys hit that like button we very much
appreciate it full length watch along as
we sync up with the time code over at
our patreon page become a super eject
today by checking all we got to offer
over there and as always uh thanks to
the boys at prepper for helping us edit
down these highlights let's get to it
[Music]
sweet
is this the whole episode i hope i would
watch this for a whole episode
oh
is this the war
it's like the actual war
that's one of the most fascinating
teasers i've
me
brought cersei a white walker
trust me
oh is our homeboy from this village
probably
oh
jeez
that was cgi blood that's some of the
best cgi blood i've ever seen
foreign
[Laughter]
oh
sorry get really close get really close
to
is
[Music]
trust
[Music]
oh
smart it's the most badass a kite has
ever been
[Applause]
it's like you guys didn't hit one of
them
jesus don't give up guys
persistence wears down resistance
it's nice to see some smiles what if you
turn them into zombies and they use
those zombies to fight the other zombies
[Music]
yeah open up those ropes let's see
what's going on
oh my god the doctor solves everything i
know mvp of the show
oh you gotta be [ __ ] killed oh my god
[Music]
i was wondering where he was
[Music]
let's just wait to hear what he has to
say all
[Laughter]
he is a traitor
what have you done man
what have you done
get this man a horse
you must be pretty embarrassed man
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
you're trying to say my wife's going to
give a baby
because
stop talking you're the smartest one in
the show
what do you viewers at home think
[Music]
oh wait does he not know what's going on
i think he's just now putting it
together he's not put together
and she's retaken for this for how many
months now
and i gave my wife away went
again
oh not like this
[Music]
this [ __ ]
oh god
[Music]
just keep thinking of your wife
[Music]
oh man it's getting the boromir
treatment
[Music]
oh god it's about sure
coward
he's practically dead
[Music]
their baby better come out swinging a
sword or something
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
[Music]
oh
man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how do you get the message
so fast out there
oh [ __ ]
god
damn it
mazel tov
oh
[Music]
what's so funny
oh man
so much physical comedy what's funny
about that how did that
cowardly magistrate guy how did he get
the message out there so fast how did he
send for them
but when did he have time yeah or
properly prep how did he summon them
because how many they only had like one
or two other horsemen with them right
they have a couple people trailing them
but it wasn't that many people unless i
got lost
that was like one person yeah not like
not like at least three or more guys
i don't know i'm not sure
man i think the original plan was to
bring them back
that because um
uh
god move because because
wanted to br he wanted i mean he was
trying to deliver him back yeah
like that was the whole goal so maybe
when they found refuge for him to rest
up before they did some acupuncture on
his face and [ __ ] that they decided
to um
i don't know send for them or something
like that yeah maybe
it was just like so sudden and then they
showed up and he was betrayed and killed
executed
what a crock of [ __ ] yeah man what a
crock of [ __ ] man he did so much for
them i know and that hot jew just cannot
let go whatever
okay so that makes sense so muy young
was under the impression that
his wife would be protected his pregnant
wife would just be under protection in
exchange for information yes
i thought he knew
yeah he was like surrendering his child
like i thought for sure like that was
something and then you see him piecing
it together like oh [ __ ] and i just gave
her up to a baby farm oh yeah yeah i
thought he was aware of that for summer
the way it read to me at the time i was
like oh he's like flat out surrendering
his kid
uh to protect her
it didn't seem like he he didn't even
say anything about the baby
it's like if you do anything to her it's
like
because if i didn't mention the kid
thought i i i thought for sure it was
like
he's aware he's giving up the baby
but
this universe snitches don't get
stitches man
nah man you get kale gourd and
boromird this is the second it didn't uh
because like anyone got boromir too
right there's been a few people just
taking hella arrows and it always hurts
well it's not gonna be
machine guns john
you know they have a cannon
cannonball somebody you know it's gonna
be a sword or arrow most likely universe
i guess it's just uh and it would make
sense for people to get lit up with
arrows it's just i feel like in most
things with aero based combat i'm used
to seeing that
piece used one time so it's cool to see
it here used
more liberally
well i i think the way they used uh the
the action scenes here because there's
such a ferocity to the way this episode
in particular escalated it was overall
executed
because were there was covering more
time than usual when you've been kicking
off with the flash well actually they
kicked off with some
it's like
i
i'm trying to understand the choice of
what they did with that flashback at the
top or when in reverse yeah but i guess
maybe that was establishing kind of the
tone of how we're going to be hopping
around time a little bit because you see
the flashback of the original time when
uh you know the show hot guy
he and
the
yeah and when they
when when they first found the
resurrection plant and used it to win
their war
so started off with that yeah and then
you're spanning all this time as our
crown prince is
uh you know winning some battles and
[ __ ] that to the point where i was like
i kind of forgot about the whole thing
with joe hawk having this whole other
side of like the kingdom i'm like oh
yeah there's there's that there's the
main plot that we gotta deal with too
yeah
and
um i say you're you're but the way they
visually realized like a lot of the
action scenes
uh was interesting here like they it
felt very
almost like no man's land
aspect to the way the apocalyptic
landscape was it was just so
everything just felt so bleak from
beginning to end
uh it feels very like hopeless and
desolate and the way they even capture
some of their action was
it's like while the opening has this
very fanciful like let's slow mo reverse
this and then a couple of cool shots
here there like some cool mounting shots
like when lord on is is beheaded and
it's in pov in the blood splat on the on
the lens or some shots on the uh
like the carriages when they're when
they're going they mount the shots here
but a lot of times like the death stuff
like even with um
muy young
it's not full boromir because he took
like an arrow over the course of like a
three minute slow motion scene
we're here just like
playing yeah
impact that they do with a lot of the
visuals here so it was cool it was neat
and
uh yeah i mean it's just uh it's just a
real it's a real sad story with our
see you bye let's say you pronounce it
an american
if it was american that's how you
pronounce it and so i'm going to say it
see you bye see you bye see you bye seo
buy
uh the her character is like
she's ultimate detective yes she did
she's like not fully putting together
like this guy might kill me if i say the
wrong thing to me
yeah that's the next step is she gotta
learn to be a little more suspicious of
her direct consortium because she puts
everything together she puts like
everything together she's an ultimate
detective she's more than just a doctor
she's a healer of a [ __ ] up
circumstances she eventually figures
everything out yeah she's the smartest
one there
and man [ __ ]
our cowardly magistrate yeah man [ __ ]
that guy uh officially lost every time i
don't like you anymore man i want to but
dude now you kind of went too far now
for me when are you people going to
learn to let go what are you going to
learn that certain things are done with
uh yeah it was uh not but they you know
yeah that really upset me yeah it really
upset me especially with him i was like
oh you've officially upset me
just when i thought you were he's never
angered me and that i was like oh you
actually got me angry yeah absolutely
this is on you and now i have a feeling
that i don't know i you never know how
these things will go but i'm sure that
there's some more in store for the
tempering and the firing of that
character now
because uh
yeah i don't know i i i i love it as a
dramatic choice but it also was the
first time i was like oh you son of a
[ __ ]
like of course we could count on you to
go through with this
i'm like he's dying and you're following
orders from a guy who you just learned
just did those worst things ever who's
brought this whole problem
like oh come on give me a break in
nations aside
give me a break
but that's the i guess that speaks to
the amount of power and fear that guy
commands because it's like if he gets
better and that's my whole goal is to
get him better
you know
he's gonna be pissed
nah ma'am
[ __ ] i didn't actually think he was a
traitor
yeah i know they i think they they did
really nicely drawing that out and i
mean like you know you can look back and
go yeah it makes a lot of sense but at
the same time
they
portrayed it really well and i mean
obviously part of that is just not
showing you when he's doing it but i
don't know they they've drawn it up into
this point in a way that to me feels
very natural like yeah we've been with
him this whole time damn you know like i
feel
betrayed even though i had the suspicion
because obviously they laid the clues
out but uh i just gave this time to just
go off on his own and travel
questions i'm like do you have a secret
falcon or something
show him like going yeah going back and
forth like when he dropped his wife off
with all the pregnant women
yes
but wasn't that that that was in a
different moment in time too though yeah
it was the past because there was a
earlier episode
there was an earlier episode
when
um
yeah but that was with the chohak people
right
yes
because there was an earlier episode
where we're all before all the women are
being killed yeah where you do see his
wife there and it's the first time i
think you'd learn that it's his wife
and he's like you look better than all
of us
yeah it was that episode and so that was
the moment that that explains how she
got there
um but still it's like
how do you have time to sneak off and do
this [ __ ]
yeah
yeah i mean there always seems to be a
bit of a distance were they staying i
don't remember our our group staying
there remember remember that incorrectly
that same land where the pregnant women
are i don't remember them being there at
that time yeah i mean i would have to go
back and comb through the details
it does beg the question i feel like
there are certain moments of probably
overlap where you could go okay you know
like the crown prince has had run-ins
with
you know various of the other chokeland
folks and stuff like that up into this
point so those present opportunities but
yeah i mean there is a lot where it's
like it seems like you two have been on
the run isolated together where like the
only times you would have to sneak away
or when like the crown prince is
sleeping or something sure which can't
be for very long so yeah i i i would
i would be curious to comb back through
and in hindsight see how much sense it
makes because yeah how do you get
how many how much word do you get out
and how frequently because they're like
i wanna know everywhere he goes and it
seems like that would be kind of hard to
do in any consistent manner um
but yeah i mean
it's funny because he started saying
that like oh he's definitely gonna die
the second we got into like the tender
moment between him and his wife and yeah
like that is a bit tropey but um i
appreciate that they really
they really gave him the moment and i
mean
it's interesting because you know
because these seasons are so compact or
at least you know so
deliberate in that they are short but
you know also as much as they seem to
need
you know uh they they are
it's like last week we had this big loss
and a big you know last crescendo last
episode so it's like three weeks like a
month ago yeah
uh you know we had you know the big sort
of crescendo for lord on and now we have
this big sort of emotional crescendo for
uh muy young and it's interesting
because it makes
feel like they're able to split the
difference nicely where it's like the
stakes feel real and anybody can you
know be taken from us but also there's
enough time to really make it you know
dramatically and emotionally satisfying
and also too i mean just across this
episode for me like i i
of all the shows we watch this one has
some of the most lucid moments of just
like wow i am so engaged by and like
inspired by the filmmaking on display
like just the way what are you gonna do
with that inspiration john do you know
anything actually make something of
yourself i'm just gonna let it be a
fleeting moment of inspiration i mean
there's only something the inspiration
only lasts for the duration of kingdom
episode which we watch once every three
and a half months so you know once we're
finished with the season i'll have
enough inspiration for a day's work i
can make something of yourself now with
this inspiration but uh no it is though
it's like it's it's there's a lot of
terrific filmmaking across all the stuff
that we get to see here but yeah some of
the ways it's okay they think
because they're taking something that is
so well worn in zombie and it's already
fresh to a degree to put that in a
period setting but even period war epics
are a genre well worn in their own ways
so the way that they're able to fuse
them in the way that they're able to
capture
things that despite the setting have
been captured a million billion times
like to make them as impactful and
visceral and sort of like you're there
as they do
but while also you know being very kind
of conscientious and clever with their
you know shot choices and whatnot like
it's i don't know it's
it's very very invigorating
to behold that's true that's very true
and uh great acting all that stuff
the crown prince especially man that
moment at the end yeah yeah like real
real sob stuff you know it's real real
tears and they're like [ __ ]
um octavia spencer you're just sucking
know but even for him like i i i love
especially his performances because this
is a character and not to say that there
aren't characters that are you know
perhaps more engrossing or more flashy
and cool to hang out with but like in a
sh in any kind of story like this i feel
like that character is often you know
your protagonist who is impactful but
not the most interesting character but
whenever he has moments like when he's
delivering that speech to the crowd of
like do you believe me now like will you
will you please like see the truth and
help me fix this and even yeah the
moments with muy young like he is so
good and i buy him so much that i'm like
yeah even he
even this character that could be good
but not ultimately like the most
engaging is still super engaging and and
you know i love what he does here too so
yeah
i hate uh
i agree
to a certain extent
that's fair
let's what's the where did the buck stop
that's i'm just messing with you yeah
all right guys well only three more
episodes left and then bye forever ever
and ever never i'm never covering
another south korean property
comment below and let us know when muy
young had the time to get all those
messages yeah yeah tell us how
we just traveled discreetly all the time
yeah i have managed to do all because it
is always sci-fi week's travels we just
feel like there'd be more scenes
of our crown prince being like where's
him you're coming back all disheveled
like oh sorry i guess she's like [ __ ]
tired yeah the last thing you told me to
do is just it took away longer than i
expected sorry chris seems like he's
always there we're all tired out here
right i feel like he's always there so
like when did you what do you sneak off
i have no idea when you're doing all
this good he is dude
that's why the crown prince trusts him
so much because he's just that good
i mean unless he dropped off pregnant
wife before they ever marked on the
mission
that was what i was taking from it but i
couldn't be honest
wrong i thought he snuck off at some
point and did i don't know you're
probably right i thought it i thought it
would make the most logical i guess it's
because we didn't see her until so late
yeah that my mind goes oh that must have
happened in between all this yeah no i
mean again it's another one of those
things where i'm like wait i want to go
back and make sure that i have all the
details straight because
i took it yeah it's like at the point in
which he and the crown prince set out
for the main part of this journey that
was like the last thing he did before
that
um so he's been a traitor this whole
time
yeah
that's [ __ ] up man
or at least much of it i suppose
straighten this out if it's before the
mission you actually started
that burns more yeah
i think good riddance yeah there's no
then no sympathy whatsoever there's two
more arrows in them one in the belly one
in the face one of the nuts
yeah
two in his butt
just complete disrespect
no
no
one of the best characters he will be
missed hopefully they'll do some kind of
sick zombie sequence with him next
episode where he's just like laying
against that tree and then you know
knocks it over and then the crown prince
cuts his head off or something
these chalk people are [ __ ] they're
the worst they're so sure there's such
like uh
there's a [ __ ] like thousands of
zombies to deal with
they're still like i still want to be
the king the kingdom yeah
we got this uh that's never good
out here
who think what's important guys you
think long term plus it'll be better if
by the time we're ruling it's just us
ruling the few of us who are left in the
ruling class
no peasants whatsoever to worry about
we'll have way more food and resources i
mean i understand i understand that this
is like historical fiction but at the
same time there's more than just korea
and japan like there's a whole world
they gotta consider but that's the goal
is we gotta get the whole world to be
conquered by korea like it gets to a
point where like how's you guys are kind
of stupid aren't you you guys are you
don't have much forsake yeah with your
incredibly planned how bad this can get
this can you it's become a worldwide
disaster if you don't get your [ __ ]
together yeah
it's like do you do they have a plan to
get rid they don't that's the part of it
like they have no plan to get rid of
them
no plan they just like just keep moving
them keep hurting them that way
like like
sweep them under this rug no it gets to
a point where like it makes no sense
what you're doing man yeah
yeah absolutely all right guys by
ambition
i know what that's like
i don't have a punchline
all right guys well thanks for being
here
and we'll catch y'all soon
[Music]